the raider image located inside allegion
stadium is a one stop shop for all
things raiders jillian lopez stopped by
to see what's what they have in store
take a look
[Music]
well the only way to arrive to a raiders
game is in style right i'm here at the
raider image inside allegion stadium
getting a behind-the-scenes look at some
of the hottest items on the shelf so
let's go do my favorite thing let's go
shopping
all right we found sequins my favorite
thing we are joined by alec the store
manager alec thank you for having us
here today this store is so cool tell us
a little bit about it and what people
can expect when they walk in so this
beautiful store is 18 000 square feet um
it's carrying everything you could even
imagine for a game day um anything from
a t-shirt to tons of sparkles
well eighteen thousand square feet of a
lot of fun stuff we're in vegas i love
that sequins are acceptable to wear to a
professional football game so there's so
much to look at let's walk over here
real quick because you told me this is a
whole new section of stuff right yeah so
this is our new line it is fabulous by
the raiderettes as you can see so
there's studs glitter glam
what else would you expect by the
raiderettes
we also have some sparkling crystals
over there as well i'm all about the
sparkles this is so much fun and we are
going to take a look at something else
with some sparkles right so as you can
see we do have a swarovski covered
helmet and we also do have this men's
jacket as well
and as you can see it does have a little
bit of strawberry crystals covered on it
as well i love everything going on here
and maybe sparkles aren't for everyone
you have a lot of other things in the
store and something really special
behind you here so this is our alumni
wall so from previous players we also do
have a hall of fame section as well for
people who want to come check out the
store when are you guys open we are open
from 11 to 8 every day and that is not
on game days right so if you need to
come in you'll have to come in before
the game okay so make sure you come get
your raiders apparel and i'm really
excited because now i get to try on a
few things
[Music]
i'm jealous of those outfits that was so
great jillian thank you there is also a
customizable jersey station by the way
you can pick a black or white jersey put
any name on the back of it and any
number and they can have it ready for
you within the same day excuse me within
about 30 minutes now the raider image is
open every day of 11 a.m and they're
closed on game days this would be a lot
of fun that's going to be cool